JAMES DONG: Good afternoon.
My name is James Dong.
I'm working on the Android
Media Team.
Today, I'm here to present you
a set of new low-level media
APIs we published in Android
that are being released.
This set of low-level media
APIs allows the Java
applications to directly access
the low-level decoding
and the encoding capabilities of
the media codecs available
on a specific Android device.
With this set of new low-level
media APIs, as Java
developers, you are given much
more flexibility and finer
granularity control on how your
media application behaves.
Today my talk is partitioned
into two parts.
In the first part, I will
briefly talk about the
existing Android media
architecture and the existing
high-level media APIs prior
to the Jelly Bean release.
In the second part, I will focus
in my talk on the new
low-level media APIs
we published in
the Jelly Bean release.
So let's start off with the
brief introduction to the
media framework architecture.
On Android-powered devices,
typically you'll see many
media-related applications, such
as a camera, music app,
gallery, YouTube, a movie
player, et cetera.
All of these applications
basically are using the same
architecture.
Each application is partitioned
into two separate
address spaces--
the application process and
the media server process.
The communication between the
application process and the
media server process is using
the Android remote procedure
call, or binder call.
In the media server process, a
set of commonly used media
services such as the
playback recording,
audio routing, provided.
The media server process then
talks to the drivers in the
kernel through a hardware
abstract layer.
For decoding and encoding
purposes, the hardware
abstraction layer is the OpenMAX
integration layer.
You can find out a detailed
reference URL basically at the
end of my slides if you
want to find out
details about OpenMAX.
So prior to the Jelly Bean
release, we already had a set
of high-level media APIs.
With these high-level media
APIs, you are able to write
applications quickly.
On this slide, I show you a
really simple example on how
to write a playback or streaming
application using a
high-level media API, which is a
media player dot Java class.
At this point, I would assume
you are pretty familiar with
the media player dot Java class,
and I will quickly walk
through the example
on this slide.
First, what you need to do is
to create a media player
object, and then set its data
source by passing it a URL.
The URL can be a local file on
your Android device, or it can
be pointing to a media data
source that is located on a
remote server.
So after you complete the media
player object, that you
can send a prepared message
message to the media object,
which basically will validate
the data source, see whether
this file format is supported
by the parser.
And if the parsing succeeded,
then you can use the common
set of media controls like
start, pause, and to control
the playback or streaming.
You can also jump to a specific
time position by
calling seek to, if the data
source is seekable.
So it depends on the interaction
between users and
the application.
This process may be to iterated
multiple times.
And then at the end of a
playback session, you want to
terminate the playback session
by calling stop.
Immediately after the
termination of the playback
session, you want to release all
the associated resources
with the media player object
by calling release.
So as you can see from this
extremely simplified example,
you do not need to write too
many lines of code, and it
provides you with a high
abstraction level on how you
can control a media playback
or streaming application.
So with this existing high-level
media API prior to
the Jelly Bean release, we are
able to meet the needs of most
commonly used media application
use cases, and we
are able to support commonly
used file formats.
In addition, we are able to
support most commonly used
streaming format protocols like
HTTP, RTSP, [? HERS. ?]
However, as a [INAUDIBLE]
Java developer, you are
often given the
challenge to do more.
So what if you are given a task
to write an application
to support a file format that
is not yet supported by the
Android platform?
What if you are given a task
to write a streaming
application to use a streaming
protocol that is not yet
supported by the Android
platform?
What if you want to do some
image processing on the output
of the decoder, and then you
send the [INAUDIBLE]
for rendering?
So what if, after the image
processing, you want to send
the output to be used as input
to an encoder, and then encode
it, and then streaming
the result out?
For these kinds of advanced
challenges, with the existing
[INAUDIBLE]
media APIs, to be honest, you
probably cannot do too much.
So that's why we publish a set
of new, low-level media APIs
in the Jelly Bean release
to address this set of
challenges.
So this new set of low-level
APIs mainly
consists of three parts.
The first part is
a file parser.
Basically it is a new class
called the media extractor.
It allows you to parse all the
currently supported file
formats on the Android
platform.
The second part of the new
low-level API is the ability
to query the abilities of the
media codecs available on an
Android device.
Why do you need this
capability?
You need to find out what's are
the available codecs so
that you can create the specific
media codec to do
decoding and encoding directly
from your application process.
So that's why you need the third
part of the API, which
is the MediaCodec
dot Java class.
So is this class provides you
the direct access of decoding
and the encoding functions of
the available media codecs on
an Android device.
So I will start with the first
part, the file parser.
Before I want to talk about the
details of the APIs in the
media extractor class, a basic
understanding on a general
file structure for a typical
media data source might help.
So a typical media data source
consists of one or more
elementary streams, which we
call "tracks." Each track
[INAUDIBLE] belong to a specific
type, like audio or
video or text.
So for each specific track, it
has one or more sample data
associated with it.
For each sample data, it can be
a decoder-specific data, or
it can be the actual compressed
access unit of
audioframe or videoframe.
So it can have the data itself,
and then also provide
the information about the media
data, such as the time
stamp you need to present
the data.
For a video purpose, it will
also tell you whether the
current sample is
a sync frame.
So with this basic understanding
on the file
structure of a typical media
source, then I will introduce
to you the first low-level
media API, which
is the media extractor.
So if you look at the media
extractor, we provide a
default constructor for you to
create an instance of a media
extractor, and then you
can use [? a set of ?]
data source which I assume you
are pretty familiar with, a
set of data source methods
similar to what media player
has to configure your
data source.
So once the data source is
configured, you can find out
the total number of available
tracks from your data source
by calling Get Track Count.
And then for each individual
track count, you can find out
a detailed format about it by
calling Get Track Format.
So Get Track Format will retain
you an object of a
media format, which is another
API we released in Android
Jelly Bean.
I'll talk about the media
format in next slide.
So in order to use the parser,
you need to select a specific
media track to use to
read data from.
In order to do that, you can
call Select a Track.
So for instance, a media data
source may have multiple audio
tracks for different languages,
so you want to
select a specific language for
your application to use.
Then, you can use
Select Track.
You can also deselect this track
so that you won't parse
data from this specific
media track.
You can also do a random seek
within the data source by
calling Seek To, which
takes two arguments.
First one is the time position
you want to seek to.
The second argument is basically
the seek mode.
So for example, if you want to
seek to a seek frame, or you
want to seek to a time position
like that is after
but the closest to
a seek frame.
So there are a number of sync
modes you can use to affect
the behavior, how you seek to
inside the data source.
If you don't want to do a random
seek, you just want to
move to next sample
position, you can
just simply call advance.
So which will move to the next
sample sequentially.
So once you reach a specific
time position, then you can
read media data or decode
specific information data
using read sample data method.
So this read sample data method
takes two arguments.
The first one is to the buffer
that you want to read the
sample data into.
The second argument basically
is to provide an offset that
you'll start to put
your data in.
It also retains an integer to
indicate whether your read is
successful, or whether
it reaches the end
of your data source.
So if it's a non-active value,
it indicates the read is
successful.
If it is a negative value,
that indicates the read
reaches the end of the stream.
So for each example, as I just
mentioned in the previous
slide, you can find a bunch
of metadata associated.
So one of the important pieces
of information is the
presentation time.
So if you wanted to find the
presentation time for that
sample, you can call Get Sample
Time, which will return
the presentation time
in microseconds.
You can also find out the flags
associated with this
particular sample, such as
whether this sample is a sync
frame, whether this sample is
decoder-specific information.
If your data source is not a
local file source, then you
need to do a cache the data.
So in order to find out how many
cached data in a RAM or
in a memory, you can use Get
Cached Duration to find out
how much amount of data is
actually cached in memory.
And you can also use Has Cache
Reached End of Stream to find
out whether the data cached in
memory already reached the end
of the stream or not.
As I mentioned earlier, in
order to find out details
about a specific media track,
you need to use a new class
called media format.
Media format dot Java class
basically encapsulates a set
of key value pairs.
And in addition to that, it also
makes available a bunch
of setters and getters methods,
so that you can find
out the value or modify
the value associated
with a given key.
For example, if you want to
find out an audio track's
number of audio channels, you
can just provide a key channel
count to find out the value
of the number of channels.
So to give you an example on
how these two APIs work, I
will show you two examples.
The first example basically
shows you a typical use of the
media extractor API we provided
So first off, you
need to create a media extractor
instance by calling
its default constructor, and
then just like your media
player object, you'll
set its data source.
So once its data source is set,
then you can find the
total available tracks from that
data source by calling
Get Track Count.
So by iterating through all the
available tracks, so you
find out the media tracks you
are interested in, and then
you'll select that specific
immediate track by calling
Select Track.
So once you select the
particular the media track you
are interested in, then you
are able to read data from
that track by calling
Read Sampled Data.
So Read Sample Data--
basically we will read a sample
from the given time
position into the buffer
[INAUDIBLE]
provider.
If the Read Sample Data returns
a negative value, that
means you already reached
the end of the stream.
If it is a positive number,
that means the read is
successful, and in addition to
the media data, you can find
out if metadata like
presentation time, sample
time, and the flags associated
with this sample.
And you can decide whether you
want to move to the next
sample by calling Advanced
Method, or you want to jump to
a random time position by
calling Seek To So once you
are done with this process,
you can iterate until you
reach the end of stream.
Once you are done with the media
extractor, then you just
call Release Method to release
all the resources associated
with this object.
So how to find out a media
track that you
are interested in.
You'll need to know the
details of the track
information.
That's why you'll need to use
this media format class.
So with this media format class,
you can find out the
MIME stream for a specific
media track.
And from the MIME stream, you
are able to tell whether this
media track is audio or video
or any other media type.
And if it is audio, you can find
out number of channels,
sample rate, by using the getter
methods I mentioned.
If it is video, you can use the
getter method, like Get
Integer to find out the
video resolution.
So the use for media format
class is really
straightforward.
I want to emphasize the file
parser, media [INAUDIBLE]
class, basically supports all
the existing formats currently
we are supporting on
Android platform.
However, if you ask to support
a file format that is not
currently supported, you
need to implement
your own file parser.
So this media [? extractor ?]
basically just provides you
an example of how you can
implement your own media
extractor to support a new
file format that is
not supported.
So that's the first part of
the low-level media API.
Now let me move on to the second
part of the media API.
Basically, it is the ability to
query the capabilities of
media codecs available
on an Android device.
So we published the
two new APIs--
MediaCodecList and
MediaCodecInfo.
So let me show you how
these two APIs work.
For MediaCodecList,
it's very simple.
There are only two public
APIs that you can call.
The first one is that you'll
find out the total number of
available codec accounts
on an Android device.
The second method--
the first one basically is the
Get Codec Count method.
The second method is the Get
Codec Info At method, which
allows you to find out the
detailed capabilities of a
specific media codec.
So you need to use the new API,
MediaCodecInfo in order
to find out detailed
capabilities of a media codec.
So the MediaCodec info class
tells you what's the codec
name for this media codec,
whether it is a
decoder or an encoder.
And you can also find out the
number of MIME types that this
specific media codec supports.
So just for your information,
the same media codec may be
able to support multiple
MIME types.
So that's why the Get Supported
Types returns an
[? array ?]
of a string.
So basically, it tells you all
the MIME types it supports.
By iterating through the
supported the types, you are
able to find out the
capabilities for a specific
MIME type for this given
media codec.
So you need this [INAUDIBLE]
class called Codec Capabilities
in order to find
out their specific capability.
So what other capabilities
exposed through this API?
Basically, two pieces
of information.
The first one is a list of
color formats that is
supported by this codec.
The second piece of information
basically is a
list of profiles and levels
supported by this media codec.
So to give you an example on
how this MediaCodecList and
MediaCodecInfo works, here
is a very simple example.
So first, you call
MediaCodecList dot Get Codec
Count to find out all
the available codecs
on a specific device.
So once you have the count, then
you can iterate through
it by calling Get Codec Info
At to find out the detailed
capability of a specific
media codec.
So this method returns you a
object of media codec info.
So using that info object, you
can find out whether this
codec is an encoder or decoder,
and then you can find
out all the MIME types it
supports by coding Get
Supported Types.
With the array of supported
types, then you can iterate
through all of them, and find
out the capability for each
MIME type that this media
codec can do.
So in this particular example, I
would like to find out which
media codec is capable of
decoding an ABC video that is
encoded in high profile
level 4.0.
So how to find out that.
And first, you can check
the type, [INAUDIBLE]
the MIME type supported by
this MediaCodec is ABC.
So basically, just check the
type against video slash ABC.
You can find out whether this
media codec supports ABC.
So if this video codec supports
ABC, then you can
find out the capabilities
of this media codec.
So there are two pieces
of information,
as I mentioned earlier.
One is the list of output color
format and the second
one is the list of profiles
and levels [INAUDIBLE].
So you can just iterate through
the list of profiles
and the levels exposed by the
capability object, and then
compare to see whether this
media codec is supporting
high-profile level four.
So the use of this
MediaCodecList and the
MediaCodecInfo API is pretty
much straightforward.
Behind the scenes, how
this API works--
for each Jelly Bean Android
device, we require a registry
XML file to be put on the
device, which actually tells
you all the available
media codecs.
So on this slide, I show you
a simple example of this
media_codecs.xml file.
So in this XML file, you can
see there are two lists of
media codec.
One list is for encoder, the
second list is for decoder.
Regardless of whether it is a
decoder instance or an encoder
instance, each media codec
entry has a single
attribute for name.
So this name tells you the media
codec name that you got
from the MediaCodec
info class.
So that's the Get Name method.
It will return you the name
attribute of the MediaCodec..
Any media codec with the
same name can support
multiple MIME types.
So if you have multiple MIME
type support for a single
media codec, you can have
multiple attributes for type.
That's why if you look at the
MediaCodecInfo class, it has a
method called Get Supported
Types, which will return all
the MIME types available in this
media codecs XML file for
a specific media codec entry.
So a media codec list, and
the MediaCodec info class
addresses the need.
Like, what are the available
media codecs on a specific
Android device?
So once you know the available
codecs, you can use a
MediaCodec class to create a
instance of that codec to
directly access the low-level
decoding or encoding
capabilities.
So how do you do that?
First, let me show you the API
available in this media codec
dot Java class.
The first three methods in this
class allow you to create
a media codec.
So the media codec can be
created either by the MIME
type you support.
Or if you know the specific name
for the media codec, you
can just pass the name.
You can create a decoding
instance or an encoding
instance this way.
Once you have a media codec
instance, then you need to
configure this media codec for
decoding or encoding purpose
using the Config method.
This Config method requires
four arguments.
The first argument
is media format.
So this media format, usually
you can get the return value
from your media extractor.
So let me go back a few
slides to show you--
see, for example, the Get Track
Format retains you the
media format object.
So you can just pass that media
format object to the
config method.
So if it's a video track, if you
decide to render the video
to a surface, you pass
the second argument--
a surface argument.
If your data source is
encrypted, then you need to
provide a media crypto-object.
The last flags basically
indicate to the API whether
this is an encoder or
decoder instance.
So why you need that is because
if the instance is
created by the third create
method, Create By Codec Name,
you are not be able to tell
whether this is for encoding
or decoding.
So that's why you need
a flag to tell--
so this config is for
decoding purpose or
for encoding purpose.
The next set of APIs basically
is a standard
set of media control.
You can do a stop [INAUDIBLE]
you can do flash.
I have a list of flash here.
I'll skip those APIs, basically
just standard media
control APIs.
In a [INAUDIBLE] media codec
API, it's basically how we
pass data back and forth between
the media process and
the application process and
the media server process.
We are using an array of byte
buffers for this purpose.
There are two arrays
of byte buffers--
one is used for input, the
second one is used for output.
The actual communication between
the your application
process and the media server
process actually is not
bypassing the byte
buffers directly.
Instead, it is passing the index
into the array, rather
than just past the
buffer directly.
So the next set of APIs
basically tells you how to use
these buffers.
So for input, you have
three methods.
The first one is Get
Input Buffers.
You only can call this method
after you start, after you
call Start.
So this method will tell you the
array of byte buffers used
for this codecs session--
either encoding session
or a decoding section.
Once you know the array of byte
buffers, then you can
find out whether there are any
input buffers available for
you to use by coding Dequeue
Input Buffer.
This Dequeue Input
Buffer takes an
argument with Timeout.
So if you give a timeout value
a negative value, basically
you just wait forever until an
input buffer is available.
Otherwise, you just wait for the
specified timeout period.
And if there is no buffer
available, it will return a
negative integer to indicate its
timeout, and there is no
input buffer available.
So if there is an available
input buffer before the
timeout period, then it will
return a valid [? binary ?]
array index, which
is basically is
a non-active value.
So using this index, you can
find out the right byte buffer
using the input array
of byte buffers.
So once you will find out the
right buffer to use, then you
can put valid input data inside
this byte buffer.
So you can either do some image
processing before you
put your data in-- that's
fine, it's up to you.
But after you prepare your data
and put it into the byte
buffer, then you can use the
next method, Queue Input
Buffer, to send this input
buffer to the codec.
So this Queue Input Buffer takes
a bunch of arguments.
Those are pretty obvious.
But I want to talk about
the first argument.
As you can see, it is indexed.
It is not the byte buffer.
So you need to pass a valid
index to this queue input
buffer, which usually you got
from the return value of
Dequeue Input Buffer.
The next argument basically is
offset, basically indicated
the starting position of your
valid data inside that byte
buffer, and the size basically
is the number of bytes of data
you put in your byte buffer.
The CDS time, US, argument
basically tells you what is
the presentation time for
this input buffer.
And the flags, basically a bunch
of flags associated with
this byte buffer flag, whether
this is a key frame.
Something like that.
So similarly for output buffer,
you can find out the
array of byte buffers by calling
Get Output Buffers.
Similarly, we are not using
the byte buffer directly
between your application and
the media server process.
We are passing the index of
the output byte buffer.
So in order to find out whether
an output buffer is
available, you'll call Dequeue
Output Buffer.
The [INAUDIBLE] value will
indicate whether you get a
valid output buffer.
If it is a negative value,
there are three cases.
It can be timed out
to indicate there
is no buffer available.
It can be indicated something
like the output format changed
for decoding applications.
Usually it happens.
So you start to decode, and then
you find out the output
buffer changed.
So the return value, a negative
return value, from
Dequeue Output Buffer will tell
you the output buffer
format changed, the output
format changed.
The third negative value that
can return from Dequeue Output
Buffer is an indication of
output buffer itself changed.
So after you receive that return
value, you need to call
the Get Output Buffer method
again to get a refresh on the
array of output buffers.
If Dequeue Output Buffer returns
a non-negative value,
meaning a valid buffer index,
then you can use that for the
subsequent call, Release
Output Buffer.
So before you call Release
Output Buffer, you may also do
some image processing on the
buffer, and using the valid
index to find out the correct
byte buffer that hosts the
data, and you can do some image
processing with that data.
And then you call this Release
Output Buffer.
Release Output Buffer,
basically,
there are two arguments.
The first one, same thing,
is an index into the
rate of byte buffers.
The second is a Boolean value.
It basically indicates whether
you want to do rendering for
this output buffer.
For video, rendering means you
want to show the video frame.
For audio, many of you
probably want to
send to audio [? sync ?]
for decoding purposes.
So for each buffer, for each
byte buffer, regardless of
whether it's input or output,
we provide you a set of
metadata associated with it.
If you look at the Dequeue
Output Buffer, the first
argument is Byte Buffer Info.
The Buffer Info object tells
you the metadata associated
with a byte buffer.
So you can find out information
like, what's the
number of bytes that this buffer
holds the valid data?
And what are the starting
positions, like the valid data
begins, inside this
byte buffer?
What is the presentation time
for this data inside the byte
buffer, and also the flags,
such as whether this byte
buffer holds a sync frame data,
or whether this holds
the decoder-specific information
or codec config
flag, or whether this actually
indicates an
end-of-stream sample.
So to show you how to
use the media codec
API, I have two slides.
The first slide basically shows
you a typical use of the
low-level media codec APIs.
So you start off by creating
a media codec instance, by
calling one of the three
Create methods.
So in this particular case, you
create a decoding instance
using the supported MIME type.
And then, you need to configure
this codec by
calling Config Method.
So the Config Method basically
needs to know the format that
this codec deals with.
That format can come from your
media extractor, if you
provide a customized media
extractor implementation, or
you use the media extractor
class we provide for you, and
by calling Get Track Format.
So that returns the right format
for you so that your
codec can deal with that
specific media track.
So once this media codec is
configured, you can just start
the decoding process
by calling Start.
After you call in Start, then it
is time to get the array of
input byte buffers and the
array of output buffers.
And you can also find out
the output format
for this media track.
Then following that,
basically, is
an iterative process--
basically you just send the
input of data to the codec to
do the decoding or encoding, and
then you get output from
the decoder or encoder.
So that's an iterative process
in the for loop, as I've shown
on the slide.
So after you are done with this
process, you stop the
decoding process, and then you
release all the resources
associated with this
media codec.
Let me go to the next slide to
show you how to actually send
input data to the decoder for
decoding, and how to get
output data from the decoder.
So this slide shows
you the details.
The first part shows you how
to send encoded data to the
decoder instance.
So firstly, you call the
Dequeue Input Buffer.
You check its return value.
If the return value is
non-negative, meaning greater
than or equal to zero, then it
is a valid buffer index,
meaning there is
an input buffer
available for you to use.
So at this point, you know which
buffer is available by
using the index, which you can
find out along with the array
of input buffers.
And you can do image processing
on the input buffer.
And once you're done with your
image processing, you can call
Queue Input Buffer with the
right buffer index.
And then that API will send
the input buffer to the
decoding instance
for decoding.
If the return value is negative,
that means probably
it's timed out, so you
need to retry.
Next, I'll show you how to get
the output from the decoder.
So you call codec dot dequeue
output buffer with a timeout.
Same thing.
It will return to you an integer
value, if it is a
non-negative value, meaning you
find basically that there
is an output buffer available.
Meaning, the decoder already
generates the output data, and
it's already stored in one
of the output buffers.
So how to find out
that byte buffer?
You use the return value from
Dequeue Output Buffer, use
that as an index into the array
of output byte buffers.
And of course, you can also
decide to do some image
processing with it.
It's up to you.
After you're done with it--
and then you can release this
output buffer back to the
output buffer array pool.
If the return value from Dequeue
Output Buffer is
negative, there are three
cases I have mentioned.
The slides only show
two cases.
So the first case is
timeout, basically.
You can check whether
it's timeout.
If it's timeout, you can retry
until you find an output
buffer available.
Otherwise, if the
return value--
if info output buffer
has changed.
That means the buffer size or
number of buffers may change.
So you need to get a refresh on
the array of byte buffers
for output.
So you call Get Output Buffers
for that purpose.
For the third case, if the
return value is info
underscore output underscore
format change, that means the
decoder will find out the
codec format basically
changed, or the subsequent
sample output will conform to
the new format.
So in order to find out the new
output format, you can use
Get Output Format for
that purpose.
So to wrap up the API for
MediaCodec, I want to mention
a couple of things more.
First, although the example
is given using a decoding
instance, most of the APIs
in this MediaCodec class
basically is the same for
encoder instance and decoder
instance so that you don't need
to learn two sides of the
different APIs.
Second thing I want to point
out is, if you're using
MediaCodec API, it is up to
the applications to do the
audio and video synchronization.
Because we return the buffer
info to tell you what's the
presentation time.
Now the opposition has the
information to do proper audio
and video synchronization.
Well, with the release of this
low-level MediaCodec API, now
it is up to you to write more
sophisticated media
applications to your
imagination.
Before I want to open the floor
for questions from the
audience, I want to thank
Andreas, in particular, for
developing the low-level
media APIs for
the Jelly Bean release.
Also, I want to point out, if
you want to find out more
information about OpenMAX spec,
you can use that URL on
the Q&A slide.
Now let me the floor for all
questions from the audience,
if there are any questions.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
your presentation.
So two questions.
One is, is the actual decoding
and encoding happening inside
of the media server
process still?
JAMES DONG: Yes, that's true.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And so in terms of a battery
consumption, if you were to
write a media player application
using these APIs
versus a natively written one,
how would they compare?
JAMES DONG: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
So we did some experiments,
although our test app is not
instrumented.
And the findings, basically, the
usual findings using the
MediaCodec API, we find out the
total power consumption
for the application basically
is roughly 10 to 20
[? milliamps ?]
above what we have using
media player class.
So a little bit more, but
I think it's acceptable.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAMES DONG: Sure.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
the presentation.
I have a question about
low-level codec APIs.
So does that means that I can
write an application to do the
realtime video chat
with those APIs?
My understanding is that those
codecs will enable leveraging
the hardware capabilities
through OpenMAX protocol
[INAUDIBLE]
JAMES DONG: That's true.
The MediaCodec API actually
allows you to access the
low-level decoding-encoding
capabilities, regardless of
whether the decoder is a
software decoder or is a
hardware decoder, or regardless
whether encoder is
an encoder or hardware
[INAUDIBLE] encoder.
So you can leverage
the hardware,
accelerate media codecs.
AUDIENCE: And my understanding
is that prior to the Jelly
Bean, those are not
exposed, right?
At least for encoding.
For the hardware [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES DONG: That's true.
That's why I said, this is a
new set of low-level media
APIs, only available in
Jelly Bean and after.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you for the answer.
JAMES DONG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
One, is there an X264
hardware-based encoder that
goes with the 4.1 that is
accessible through the
low-level APIs?
JAMES DONG: To answer
your question, yes.
For example, the current
device, for example,
[INAUDIBLE]
and the prime [INAUDIBLE]
provide you the
hardware-accelerated ABC
decoder, which are able to
decode ABC high-profile
level four videos.
So really, it depends on
the device capability.
So if you have a low-end device,
you may not be able to
have the hardware to do that.
So that's why you need
that capability
query API to find out.
AUDIENCE: And my second
question, is there an RTSP
streaming component that could
integrate with the encoders?
That work with the new
media [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMES DONG: RTSP streaming--?
AUDIENCE: Servers.
JAMES DONG: Servers
we do not have.
We have a client
implementation.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
First of all, with the release
of Jelly Bean are you adding
any extra codecs that kind of
implement these APIs that
would serve as good examples?
JAMES DONG: Your question
basically asked whether we
have additional media codecs
to support the--?
AUDIENCE: That were added in
Jelly Bean versus [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES DONG: Jelly Bean?
Well, this really depends
on the device you have.
But the commonly available
codecs are basically, for
video, you have ABC decoder,
ABC encoder.
You have a MPEG-4 video
encoder-decoder.
You have a H263 encoder-decoder
you would
expect it to have on a commonly
available Android device.
For audio, you have a
bunch of formats to
support decoder for MP3.
For encoder, you have an AAC,
AMR, narrow band, wider band.
So all of those are supported.
AUDIENCE: Second, you kind of
mentioned the media crypto, I
believe it was, for the actual
DRM, I would assume,
production.
Can you go into a little more
detail on what would be
involved in using that
in your app?
JAMES DONG: Yeah, that's
unfortunately out of the scope
of this presentation,
which is another,
basically, talk in itself.
But basically, we published
a new API called the media
crypto cast.
You can do a decoding of
encrypted content.
So currently, we implement
this and verify it with
Widevine DRM, Widevine
encrypted content.
Does that answer
your question?
Otherwise, it's another long
talk, basically, about media
crypto API.
So once the API is published,
you can look at it.
It's pretty simple, also.
AUDIENCE: The APIs
are going to be--
JAMES DONG: For media crypto.
AUDIENCE: When is the actual
documentation of that going to
be totally available?
JAMES DONG: It's going to be
released with the SDK.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great, thanks.
JAMES DONG: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
in the configuration
that it uses surface.
What does it use that
for, that value?
JAMES DONG: OK.
The second argument
for configured
method is the surface.
So if you want to render your
video output, for example,
then you want to pass a surface
so that you can render
that video output for
that purpose.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And how does that work with
the syncing of the audio?
Would you render the movie and
then have another thread
that's parsing your audio?
JAMES DONG: Yeah.
It's up to the application,
basically.
You probably need to write
multiple threads.
One thread is handling the
video, the other thread is
handling the audio.
But it's up to the application
to do that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you just passed the surface
for us to use.
JAMES DONG: Yes.
We just passed the surface
as the video sync.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
JAMES DONG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In Ice Cream Sandwich, you
released a new low-level
streaming API.
Will Jelly Bean build upon
or replace that one?
JAMES DONG: Sorry, let
me turn this one off.
Sorry, what was your
question again?
AUDIENCE: In Ice Cream Sandwich,
you released the new
OpenMAX AL streaming
low-level library.
Will Jelly Bean replace
or build upon that?
JAMES DONG: Well,
it's used for a
different purpose, basically.
And I think from Jelly Bean and
on, we should to focus on
MediaCodecs API.
AUDIENCE: Will the ICS1 still
be supported, then?
JAMES DONG: It will be
still supported.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then you mentioned
media crypto.
Is there a way to protect the
decrypted yet still encoded
data using media crypto?
JAMES DONG: Yes.
For encrypted content, actually,
you are not able to
actually access the output
by the buffer.
So it's opaque data,
basically, to
the application process.
So if you have hardware-assisted
protection
for your video pass, then the
output buffer actually is
hardware-protected.
AUDIENCE: Does it just support
Widevine, or do custom DRMs
support it, too?
JAMES DONG: Currently, the only
verified implementation
is with Widevine.
But I can imagine you're
also able to
work with other schemes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
JAMES DONG: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My first question is,
is there any constraint
for threading access
of these buffers?
Say [INAUDIBLE]
different threads for collecting
data and maybe
another to call a codec.
So is there any constraint
on thread [? parts ?]
for accessing the input
buffer or the buffer?
JAMES DONG: Sorry,
can you repeat--?
AUDIENCE: I'll make it simple.
When I access the input buffer
and output buffer, can I use
[INAUDIBLE]
thread?
Is there any constraint
for it?
JAMES DONG: No, there
shouldn't be.
As long as you have a valid
input buffer or output buffer,
you can use it for
your own purpose.
AUDIENCE: OK.
My second question is, you
mentioned about the
[INAUDIBLE]
decoder.
Is there any way to get to the
hardware color converging?
Like, YUV to RGB?
JAMES DONG: So, there was no API
we published in Jelly Bean
for that purpose, for
color conversion.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And you mentioned the codec
information can tell the
profile and the level
[? supported. ?]
Is there any way to
know a profile or
level of a media source?
JAMES DONG: The profile
and the levels
for the media source.
No, currently, we are
not supporting that.
So as an application developer,
you need to know
the source, basically.
AUDIENCE: Maybe not.
JAMES DONG: If you don't know
it, then the codec API will
indicate, it is not able to
handle if the codec is not
available to handle.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
read the document.
Is there any arrow
codec since--?
JAMES DONG: There is--
well, for example, the Set
Data Source and Get Track
Count, you may not get the
right number if the file
format is not supported,
for example.
AUDIENCE: Say for the audio
is supported, video is not
supported, so maybe a check
account would be
one instead of two?
JAMES DONG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And my last minor question is,
in your code showing in the
[? spring, ?]
you used two equal to compare
the codec [INAUDIBLE].
Is it safe?
JAMES DONG: Two equals?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Two equals.
Instead of a color stream,
you closed two--
JAMES DONG: Yeah, that's
the probably my--
yeah.
But basically, just to compare
the MIME type against the
supported MIME type.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
JAMES DONG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
You haven't mentioned the
Android indicator.
So are the same set of API
changes also available from
the native side, like
from the NDK side?
JAMES DONG: No.
This is all Java API.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And have there been any changes
to the NDK exposed
APIs at all for Jelly Bean?
JAMES DONG: Not as
far as I know.
This is just Java APIs,
not related to NDKs.
AUDIENCE: From that looks of
your sample code, it's really
just the thin wraparound from
some native code, like most
[? of the ?]
[? classes ?]?
JAMES DONG: Yes.
Those will be available at the
native layer, but it's not a
part of NDK.
AUDIENCE: So you can't actually
call these from--
JAMES DONG: No, we are not
recommending you to call
directly into the native code.
AUDIENCE: Because some audio
APIs are actually
exposed in the NDK.
JAMES DONG: Yeah.
Firstly, in the NDK, you
have the guarantee we
will maintain it.
But if it's not a part of the
NDK, then we may change it.
AUDIENCE: If you want to write
some really low-latency codes,
for example, and you have,
you're calling a native code
anyway, so it kind of makes
sense to actually expose these
codecs natively.
JAMES DONG: Yeah.
But for the Jelly Bean
release, we are
not supporting it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
JAMES DONG: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned about we need
to do the way we do RGB
conversion.
So can the surface be backed
by a surface texture?
In that case, would we get
something as a [INAUDIBLE]
texture, and we can
use a [? GL ?]
to do the color conversion?
JAMES DONG: Sorry, I haven't
mentioned that.
But it's up to you to do
the image processing.
Not necessary to do
color conversion.
So the media API basically gives
you the raw data, like
the output of uncompressed
video frame, for example.
You can do image processing
on it,
AUDIENCE: It is in
what format?
It is RGB?
JAMES DONG: Well, the format,
it will tell you, basically,
you can call Get
Audible Format.
You can find out what
the format there.
AUDIENCE: And it is expected
to be in an RGB format, and
not in an intermediate
[INAUDIBLE] format, is it?
JAMES DONG: No.
It's a decode output, so it
could be, mostly it is,
[INAUDIBLE]
output format.
AUDIENCE: So that means we
need to do the color
conversion.
JAMES DONG: Well, it depends
on how you do your image
processing, yes.
AUDIENCE: So if you don't do
image processing, and we just
say, Boolean rendered to be
true, the underlying platform
will do the color conversion and
render it to the surface?
JAMES DONG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And are these
buffers getting
copied in any way?
Like, the decoder could use the
decoder resources to push
the decoded buffers.
Is it getting copied from the
GPU memory to CPU memory?
JAMES DONG: Well, we try to
avoid mem copies as much as we
can, and as far as I know, there
is no copy at all at the
media level.
And the only traffic
communication added for this
media API is the indices of this
input buffer and output
buffer arrays.
Basically, that's the added
communication traffic between
the application and the
media server process.
AUDIENCE: But then, if the
decoder is using GPU memory,
and if it has to be passed
as a [INAUDIBLE]
into Java, wouldn't it have to
be a non-GPU memory for the
application to do any kind
of post-processing?
JAMES DONG: Well, the byte
buffer array is basically just
a wrap-around of the
native buffers.
You may not necessarily see a
specific format for that.
AUDIENCE: So it could
be textures, too?
JAMES DONG: It could be.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And how do we know if it's
a texture or not?
JAMES DONG: You don't
know at this point.
There is no API to help
you about it.
AUDIENCE: But if you have to do
post-processing, we should
know how it is represented
inside the byte buffer, right,
in order to read those datas?
JAMES DONG: Well, that data
itself actually is arranged in
a way that you can access it,
basically find out the output,
the [INAUDIBLE]
format, and the size of it.
AUDIENCE: I see.
And the encoded data is passed
as like elementary strings?
JAMES DONG: Sorry, I think we
are running out of time, and
we can take this offline.
All right?
OK.
Thank you.